our viewers may know that the 777 has a
remarkable safety record only three 777s
have ever crashed a British Airways 777
while landing at Heathrow there were no
fatalities last summer of course the
Asiana crash in San Francisco and the
missing Malaysian 777 and that's a point
worth emphasizing that a Malaysian
Airlines is now appears to be the victim
of two disasters in fairly short order
the plane that still has not been found
presumed lost over the southern Indian
Ocean
and now a plane that appears to have
been shot down this is according to the
Ukrainian interior ministry
you heard Olivia Sterns bringing that
news to us just moments ago that
Ukrainian rebels appear to have shot
down a Malaysian Airlines 777 near the
Russian and Ukrainian border if that is
the case a tragedy of unspeakable the
gravity that this could actually happen
in the midst of the dispute over the
future of Ukraine Stephanie I I actually
want to take a look at the markets as
soon as we saw these headlines cross we
saw a big leg down broader markets dow
and SP both took a serious dip worse
receipt we are now seeing somewhat of a
recovery as more information is coming
out but the uncertainty in general has a
negative effect on the markets we are
going to be watching it closely that is
the Dow down 43 points we are going to
have more on this crash and apparent
shooting down of a Malaysian 777 Boeing
777